42 countries have ratified the Minamata  convention a global treaty to protect  human health and the environment from  the adverse effects of mercury mep s  gave the green light for the EU to do so  as well it's the fourth time Hungarian  leader Viktor Orban came to speak in  Parliament this time concerning a new  law to threaten the shut down a  university  the Commission has opened a legal case  against Hungary a yearly fund the 600  million year as turkey could be halted  if talks on its EU membership are  formally suspended something some any  piece called for Eurogroup chief Dyson  will finally joined a debate on the  Greek crisis parliament president piane  had previously called it out for having  turned down the invitation three times  in a row young children spent 88 minutes  a day online the committee vote  advocated stricter rules for new media  platforms to better protect minor